so if I were to tell you that the London
Underground was covered in webs what's
the first thing you'd think of that's
right Yeti's Doctor Who classic and this
review is brought to you by patreon my
patreon specifically because when I do
classic reviews which one I do does get
voted on by my patreon supporters I'm
getting that plug in there because
literally every little bit helps
I seriously they even the lowest here is
very helpful ok moving on so this is a
second doctor adventure it is the second
appearance of the great intelligence
villain it is the first appearance of
Brigadier lethbridge-stewart although
he's only a colonel when we see him here
it's the second doctor so it's Patrick
Troughton it's Jamie McCrimmon who is
you know that they are some of my
favorite doctor companion pairings ever
it's got Victoria who's there and it's
gotten some of the better location
shooting because they did actually get
to shoot in the London under-underground
so yeah this one I hadn't seen before
and if you do watch it be aware that the
third episode is still missing so what
that one is is there for that episode
you get a series of still images and the
audio is still around but you don't
actually get video on there you can you
can follow what's going on in the nature
of that episode it's not too difficult
to track but just be aware of that so
plot wise oh actually it's probably
worth mentioning um if you haven't seen
enemy the enemy of the world yet you may
want to watch that one before watching
this one because this one picks up like
immediately on a cliffhanger that that
story ended on
and when they sort of talk you know
coming out of that situation some of the
things they talk about also indicate how
the villain was defeated in that
previous story so I haven't seen enemy
of the world yet but I now know how the
villain is defeated so I guess that's
just the heads up there
in any case Jamie Victoria and of course
the doctor in the TARDIS find themselves
suddenly stuck wrapped up in webbing and
then forced to land the TARDIS in the
London Underground and then we get the
appearance of the yetis which
immediately indicates the great
intelligence now if you only know modern
era Doctor Who the great intelligence
was well it showed up in the snowmen and
then in the bells of st. John and then
in the name of the doctor and it is kind
of a it is a it is an intelligence
without form it does not have a body it
can take control and manipulate various
things including people but it it does
not have a physical form so there's a
number of things that play here and some
of them are quite interesting so we've
got kind of the claustrophobic setting
of the London Underground which has been
infected with it looks like webbing but
they call it a fungus which is growing
and making more and more and more of the
areas you know I you man to travel there
you've got the yetis wandering around so
you've got you've got tense atmosphere
you have an encroaching threat you have
monsters it has that base under siege
vibe that kind of claustrophobic vibe
and like I said because they got to use
the actual London Underground it looks
pretty good especially for Doctor Who at
the time I was actually surprised how
good the yetis look I've said before
that black and white film really it it
can be really forgiving of some
otherwise very wonky effects and the
yetis actually looked surprisingly good
except for the one episode where where
it's actually above ground and we see
them wandering around the streets in
wide shots in broad daylight
yeah they don't look good then but in
the tighter shots in the tunnels and the
corridors of the one
no they look pretty good and and and
they work pretty well so you've got
military forces down there trying to
figure out how to beat all this stuff
back and not having a lot of luck at the
time the doctor does campaign's land
they're trying to detonate stuff
collapse tunnels nothing is really
working at all
now also makes up in this is Professor
Travers now he is a recurring character
because he was involved in the story the
abominable snowman which was the first
story with the great intelligence and
the Yeti so when the doctor and his
companions throw out was throw up show
up and they run into him you know it
takes him a minute like whoa God you
really do have a time machine because
you have an age today but you know they
have an ally on the ground who's been
involved with this kind of stuff with
them before the guy who plays him is
interesting he like he seems to dial it
back as tight as the episodes gone but
his very first episode holy cow that
that was some really amazing overacting
that he does in that very first episode
because like he would lock his head he
wouldn't move his head but then he would
do this incredibly exaggerated line
reading and these lip movements and the
eyebrows would go mad but the head was
locked in place it was very strange like
I said he seemed to dial it back in
later episodes or whatever the director
told him to knock it off or something
was that was kind of interesting he's
also got his his daughter on hand who's
a scientist I rather an was her name I
actually rather liked her because you
actually get a soldier as here so you
know what are you doing a place like
this and just goes well I was a little
girl I thought I might want to be a
scientist so I became one like I guess
that's the perfect answer I like her and
you've also got an odd mix of characters
I mentioned the Brig
and I know again he's not a brigadier
yet I'm so
on that you've got this sort of Sonia
on-the-ground sergeant type there's uh
there's a reporter it's kind of a
Weasley not particularly trustworthy guy
there's a there's a there's a guy who's
normally not somebody who you know he's
in the army but normally wouldn't hand
him a gun and send him anywhere he's a
driver primarily now there's it's it's
funny because the one another thing that
it seems to be pulling some of its vibes
from and I don't know if the original
novella was written before this came out
but it would be
who goes there which was the story that
inspired the thing from another world
and then eventually the thing um in that
one of the things about the great
intelligence is because it can kind of
overtake Minds under certain
circumstances there is the fear that
there is somebody in their midst who is
in cahoots with the great intelligence
and so there's a little bit of that
paranoia going on and characters kind of
like a little bit kind of trust you kind
of trust you and of course this being
the first time we meet the break you
know they don't trust him
and so there's that kind of thing going
on and it's interesting enough that it
kind of works with what for me would
have otherwise been a notable complaint
although it still did bug me as I
watched it which is that there are more
characters that get a devoted amounts of
screen time than I would normally like
to see and what and I mean that kind of
in a fairly specific way because
normally one of the things I like about
classic who is the fact that these
stories overall take longer to tell we
get to know the supporting cast more the
problem is here a lot of the supporting
cast don't seem to have a function other
than to bulk out the cast numbers
because like the reporter doesn't really
do anything that drives the story the
coward doesn't really do anything that
drives the story there's a handful of
other you know kind of officers or or or
what-have-you that are basically
interchangeable and don't really do
anything to move the story forward but
the reason that their their narrative ly
and functionally is to have a large
enough pool to have the paranoia happen
because if you've only got like
basically only characters that we've
known before like to new people well
it's got to be fairly easy to figure out
who's working for the who's working with
the great intelligence here so I get why
they needed a bulk doubt cast I just and
and I'm not even gonna say that it
doesn't work it just they are character
archetypes and kind of non-functional in
the narrative other than the story
benefits from there being more named
characters than then you would otherwise
put in this particular story it's
probably a little long - it's six
episodes it probably well it definitely
could have been five it probably could
have even gotten away with four there's
some very extended sequences of
basically the doctor and other people
just tinkering with stuff
that just kind of dragged a little bit
and I mentioned the the one above-ground
action scene yeah that really that
should not have been filmed that was uh
I was not pretty at all like bless their
hearts for trying it's um but it doesn't
look very good but I overall I was I was
quite happy with this obviously you know
Troughton is top of his game he's
absolutely phenomenal with this and him
and Jamie I will always love Jamie's one
of my favorite companions and I
mentioned Victoria Victoria she just was
one of those commands who was there to
mostly scream as needed and occasionally
get captured and that's basically all
she does here she's got decent enough
performance chemistry with the other
actors so that it's not too too bad but
you know she doesn't bring a lot to the
table and it's it's always gonna be
Jamie and the doctor the second doctor
that's always gonna be the pair that I'm
like yeah so but seeing them together
the yetis work pretty well the idea of
the intelligence actually is pretty well
executed and and as much as I I did sort
of complain a little bit I don't know
about all these characters the the vibe
of the paranoia combined wid the more
claustrophobic feel combined with the
monsters that as long as they're not in
daylight actually look pretty good it's
solid early Doctor Who
era story I gotta say overall so the web
of fear introduces a whole lot of cool
stuff have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do because there's buttons there's
links patreon merch more click on them
they'll take you places or don't if you
don't want to you don't have to because
at the end of the day folks you are the
council
I'm just running the meetings it's so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]